[Musique]
au menu ce midi crudités sauter de serre
écrasé de pommes de terre poêlée de
légumes fromage et fruits pour ce
premier repas de la semaine du goût les
collégiens de volgelsheim sont choyés
d'autant plus que dans le haut rhin à la
semaine du goût se rajoutent l'opération
manger bio et local
c'est génial ainsi depuis 2012 trois
fois par an cette initiative du conseil
départemental entend proposer des
produits locaux dans les repas des
cantines c'est pour vraiment promouvoir
toute la filière de proximité et en plus
on a rajouté la filière de biologique en
alsace
donc avec différents partenaires la
chambre d'agriculture
l'interprofession des fruits et légumes
d'alsace l'organisation également
professionnels les agriculteurs bio
d'alsace et bien sûr la direction
régionale de l'alimentation et de la
forêt donc tous ses partenaires
travaillent avec nous pour que nos
enfants dans les collèges mange mieux
mange mieux manger sainement et surtout
apprennent à manger également en
fonction des saisons
pour cette édition les équipes de 25
collèges se sont mobilisés et ainsi près
de 13000 élèves sont 18 verront leur
repas passer au bio et local derrière
ces opérations ponctuelles l'idée
d'initier une démarche quotidienne des
établissements qu'on voit qu'on va dans
les collèges acquis à il ya une
proposition de produits bio qui de fait
qui est fait de façon plus régulière et
les animations permettent à la fois de
valoriser les filières mais aussi le
travail des équipes qui contrairement
aux idées reçues ont du talent en point
de cette démarche le collège de
volgelsheim propres d'ores et déjà
prodigué quotidien mais avant de
déguster il faut produire et récolté ça
se passe à seulement 5 minutes du
collège sur l'exploitation de dany
schmidt la ferme pulver mule ici on
produit une grande variété de fruits et
légumes en agriculture biologique
une affaire de famille depuis six
générations aujourd'hui oui pour nous
c'est très important de pouvoir fournir
le collège qui est juste à côté de nous
et surtout de pouvoir proposer aux
jeunes nos enfants une alimentation
saine et de proximité et de les amener
vers
une consommation locale et une
consommation de produits de qualité
c'est une fierté d'autant plus que c'est
un collège dans lequel je suis passé
aussi mes enfants ils sont passés mes
petits-enfants ils sont donc évidemment
c'est une grande fierté
on retrouve nos carottes de la ferme
dans les cuisines du collège pour
l'équipe travaillé ces produits est un
véritable plaisir
on a des produits de très grande qualité
et qui ont un goût en plus un vraiment
un goût qu'on reconnaît qu'ils sont et
qui est beaucoup plus agréable à
travailler également on travaille
quotidiennement à peu près une géré par
semaine ça va entre 110 150 kilos ça
peut aller par semaine en produits frais
de cette ferme là donc en fonction des
saisons
c'est vrai que septembre octobre c'est
propice en a beaucoup de produire un
point vraiment l'époque du village si
aujourd'hui la cantine propose
quotidiennement une part non négligeable
de produits bio et locaux
c'est qu'il y avait ici une bonne
alchimie producteurs cuisiniers et
direction de l'établissement ont su
trouver le bon tempo pour le plus grand
bénéfice de tous nous avons la chance
d'avoir d'abord un chef de cuisine
monsieur bernonville qui est quelqu'un
de très investi dans son domaine et où
nous avons la chance d'avoir une équipe
de restauration qui est particulièrement
dynamique
alors c'est une volonté de l'équipe de
cuisine mais c'est une volonté aussi du
chef d'établissement
ça fait partie de l'éducation culinaire
de nos élèves et donc je souhaite
vraiment que nous puissions faire
travailler des producteurs locaux sur la
la fourniture de nous de nos produits en
moyenne 30% plus cher que le
conventionnel
le bio peut faire peur un coût important
pour les établissements qui se lance si
de nombreux parents seraient ravis de
voir leurs enfants manger plus sainement
quand il s'agit de voir le prix du riz
augmente et beaucoup ce sera 10
pourtant à volgelsheim le saut
qualitatif ne s'est pas fait au
détriment du porte monnaie
nous avons un suivi au quotidien des
dépenses donc c'est tout à fait
équilibrée nous avons réussi sans
augmenter les tarifs de la demi-pension
à introduire le bio local au sein de
l'alimentation après évidemment ça a
demandé des aménagements puisque
l'équipe de cuisine doit transformer les
produits c'est-à-dire qu'ils arrivent
tel quel et il faut donc il ya un
travail bien plus important de main
d'oeuvre au quotidien donc forcément une
charge de travail un peu plus lourd pour
l'équipe mais comme il ya beaucoup de
bonne volonté et beaucoup de dynamisme
dans cette équipe ça a permis de serre
de fournir des repas de qualité au
quotidien autre difficulté créé les
bonnes connexions entre les producteurs
et les cuisiniers les collèges habitués
les uns et les autres à travailler
ensemble pour cela le conseil
départemental ce placement facilitateur
pour organiser donc cette émulsion entre
les collèges les producteurs on
s'entoure de partenaires et notamment de
la chambre d'agriculture d'alsace à qui
elle va mettre en lien et les
producteurs avec les collèges alors nous
avons toujours avec de très bonnes
relations et le conseil départemental
avec des interlocuteurs privilégiés qui
sont très présents qui nous accompagnent
ils nous soutiennent aussi dont a fait
des demandes de subventions donc
derrière et on a une vraie que vraie
aide de la part des services que nous
remercions donc c'est vrai que c'est ce
travail de collaboration qui nous permet
d'avoir un résultat aussi positif
aujourd'hui derrière ses opérations
autour du bio et du local de nombreux
enjeux le truc avec la culture
alsacienne l'éducation au groupe
la valorisation des produits la chasse
au gaspillage
mais aussi l'importante question de
santé publique un enfant qui mangent
bien qui apprend à manger équilibré qui
apprend à manger des fruits et des
aliments de saison c'est ici un bienfait
pour sa santé si elle bien fait pour un
fléau qui nous concerne un peu tous
c'est-à-dire l'obésité a également qui
commence tout petit salut apprend
également peut-être à manger le fait de
manger en cantine
il ne mange pas devant la télé ils
mangent pas devant des écrans il mange
avec d'autres personnes et il apprend à
déguster en prenant leur repas
les collégiennes peut-être pas compte de
tous ces bienfaits mais les retours
semblent très positif alors les retours
sont très bons parce que d'abord il y à
une éducation au goût qui est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus intéressante donc au
niveau des saveurs et le retour que ce
soit au niveau des parents et des élèves
est tout à fait favorable pour un légume
ça reste un légume après le but c'est
vraiment leur faire leur faire goûter
manger ses légumes
on part un peu la découverte ont fait
pas mal de choses donc après on apprend
on espère que ça marche mais il reste
toujours un petit quelque chose
il reste toujours un petit quelque chose
et qui sait peut-être un jour permet les
épinards aux adolescents